know some friends glowed up off a kick
those at times for kicks others when
times were stick though
hen licks with guns big cannons run with
big sticks with drums
nick cannon funds have expanded since
like it spandex but don't fix
damages all i had was sir the fake
sandwiches
she had to stick to mama stamps come in
not either rash and captain crunch i eat
naps for lunch i'm fasting
buckle stunk unfashion truck crashing
much is a cut plus my hat done shrunk
brush your [ __ ] hell uh your
naps going punch
challenging myself to be better going
over beats better than most of elites i
leak excellence big puppy roll over and
leap then keep pedaling freak sucking me
out of my sleep like she freddie
smart [ __ ] living by rules the streets
set up [ __ ] y'all [ __ ] ain't follow
rules since meet jetta
who's the king better be do with wings
feathers and pooches who's better
arguments been settled
cupid spit arrows that boost my blue
jealous i blew in new areas you claimed
you flaring up
you dudes just ain't rare enough good
guardian guiding me good god it's a
giant the hood swallowing me
all of the good parts of me dying i'm
shook shot from the lightning i stood
tall and invited it
just got good jog through a gutting
environment through the jungle with
lines you good at juggling lies [ __ ]
40 and my brother draws who you feeling
raw [ __ ] pull up with other cause who
you finna mod with
pull up like dirty drawers with a 30
round clip i know how the blood run i
know how that i feel
my spine tingle from smells my mind
remember well my eyes even impale we
nine deep in the shell
anything i can get with five fingers for
sale nine fingers at 12
time wrinkling i'm only five feet from
the edge these lines keeping me here
my mind keeping me here these sounds
keeping me here
headphones in i'm trying to leave from
his head
you